i'm watching your body language as
you're telling your story i get two
sides here
i see a side if i didn't know you know i
met you for the first time and i saw you
at a restaurant
i'd say this guy's a
gentle sweet
you know
the way you talk calm all that stuff
right on the way you speak i don't know
if you guys get that feeling that's the
feeling i get a very sweet gentle side
right
how are you hiding that rage
inside how did you do that because
there's no way in the flipping
world that you
are going to be able to live that kind
of a life have that kind of trauma have
that kind of animosity on what was done
where nobody can describe that to you
this is your life this is not a movie
this is not a book this is not a
article we're reading
how are you managing that rage because
the same way as you're gentle
on the other side special ops i know
what it is you know the special ops i
hung out with those guys you know
whether it was delta i was about to
become 18 18 uh delta with fifth group
at fort campbell kentucky i went and
interviewed a lot of guys like you and i
said i'm gonna go a different direction
i got out of the military
how do you manage that gentle side and
the rage side
you know pastor i'm going to put you in
my worst day
you know it's through the struggles
right when i said no i'm going to put
you through this day you know i i was uh
i was eight years old and people always
ask me too what's your first memories of
america i'll tell you
my mother took me to a grocery store and
she she bought all this food and look
that
i don't mean anything to you guys but
i'm telling you when you starve and
you're in refugee camps for a year and a
half that means everything
and then she was so happy she took she
took me out it was mother and sunday you
know we were loading the groceries into
the car and this man came up to me
and he spit in my face and he flicked my
mom off and he told me to go home he
called me [ __ ]
this is in america eight years old
carolina
that was my first memories
of america
unpopular vietnam war and i was the
image of an unpopular vietnam war and
when i was eight
i went to uh school i was very poor had
holes all my clothes
you know we uh we live in a four-part
town i was reminded how poor i was every
day
uh we went in school it was substitute
teacher day and uh my name is pronounced
in vietnamese right but i say two lambs
so you guys don't mess up my vietnamese
name so um it was sub two teacher day he
called my name and obviously he said it
wrong and everybody made fun of me
everybody's throwing papers at me
reminded me how poor i was
and there was this bullying he made fun
of me made slanted eyes and we we both
got in trouble right i don't know how i
got in trouble i got in trouble i know
he went down to the principal's office
and the principal sat us down he told
our parents need to come pick us up
my mom didn't drive at a time so i knew
i was going to be there for a while and
then the bully's mother came in first
and she demanded no it's wrong the
principal stood up and he looked over
and he goes your son caught that boy
right there a [ __ ]
i sat back down
the mother went in the corner she picked
up her son walked over to me and you
know how somebody stands there you have
to look up because i was looking at the
ground was already defeated
i looked up and she said my son is right
you don't belong here and you need to go
back home
to your country
you're eight years old my
i tried so hard i hyperventilated and
principal said boy you're going to cry
like that you need to go in the hall
and that night i came home i didn't even
talk to my mom i was so upset
and my mother came in
i didn't even eat dinner she came in she
sat down next to me she said son there
will be the bad days
but what do you learn from it
never ask me what everything that
happened or anything's wrong i knew at
that point
that i got tired of being this huge weak
human being you know i was escaped from
war i found you know i faced death i
faced you know the refugee camps
and i got tired of being this weak human
being
so i made a promise to myself that day i
was going to be stronger than hate but
what's that even look like right so what
what what what you see in me patrick is
i have rage
it's there and i can switch it on and
off at any second
but it's like a weapon i can safety that
gun
right because i drive as a warrior i
drive off of compassion
so so let's let's go through this okay
uh when you when you said that i'm
trying to see how that trauma affected
me i'm a kid i come to the states
uh when i came here was seventh grade so
whatever seventh grade is i'm 12 years
old and i'm coming here and my english
sucked so for me they would i had a hard
time pronouncing uh
government i would say government had a
hard time pronouncing wednesday i would
say wednesday
because of that end that's there it
really screws the whole thing up whoever
came up with that name they need to be
fired as you know right now uh there was
a show called gilligan's island i would
say gilligan's island because that s is
there why the hell would you put an s
there what's the problem with these guys
here right i'm sure you struggled with
lasagna lasagna and that was easy
because my mother made lasagna but fresh
off the boat you know hey you're fresh
you're phobe you're fresh off the boat
i'm like i'm gonna buy the damn boat one
do you guys me off right but that rage
was either going into humor
to lighten the load because you have to
be like hey funny all this other stuff
you know it's the humor side to kind of
calm me down a lot of times comedians
have lived a very difficult life what
did you do with it like did you put it
in martial arts did you put it at 13 14
years old in sports did you put it in
fighting kids like were you the guy we
had a guy in school's name was andy
asian guy
and uh this guy would walk so calm one
time a guy called him something a good
friend of mine
he didn't just beat the guy he almost
killed the guy we had to pick him we
couldn't even pick this guy up he was
like gonna kill this kid if we didn't
stop him
the right and he went from a calm sweet
kid
to a guy capable of killing somebody
where did you release your tension and
anger into what was that for you as a
young teenager
you know i i
i was raised my stepfather was special
forces my own cool special forces so i
was raised in fayetteville outside fort
bragg the biggest
special operations second right more
commandos walked there
than anywhere in the united states i was
raised around that but
when you asked me what my outlet was
you know patrick i was beaten
i was bullied my whole my whole
all the way to high school
um
my outlet was um
you know my spending time with my father
the special forces
but i knew let me bring you to this day
so i i was being picked on with spit on
clothes you know being ripped off me
just remind how poor i was and my uncle
special forces american spirit he was
the one who founded our paperwork to get
us to the united
american special forces he was an
officer his g base guy overran vietnam
he got stabbed by sks he backed out
this guy's
he's an amazing american and my uncle
picked me up right
and he drove me in he must have said
something's wrong with me that day
because he he said something i'm just
out of blue
he said you know two
there'll be days
that people are going to spit on you and
they're going to judge you're going to
flick you off and they're going to say
you don't belong here
you need to ask yourself
do you want to be a [ __ ] commando
today you know when your bones ache
and you found all your injuries and you
you just want to quit on life you need
to ask yourself do you want to be a
[ __ ] commander then when it's cold
outside it's raining and you know the
right thing to do is to get up
and exercise your body because you're
this weapon that america needs you need
to ask yourself if you're going to be a
[ __ ] commando today
and i was 11.
can you imagine
the impact that meant
command or a life of discipline when i'm
so weak and being picked on
see i don't think you were weak though
because it would have broken a lot of
people yeah you weren't weak you were
just you didn't know how to take control
yet you didn't know how to set
boundaries you didn't you were you were
not weak and not not to disagree with
your life story forgive me but you know
that would have broken a lot a lot a lot
of people man and you know jordan
peterson has a great saying that only
the violent are capable of peace
because if you're not capable of
violence you're incapable of peace
you're obedient you're subservient
only people capable of violence can
choose to be peaceful
you know everybody else it's not your
choice
so i mean in that regard it sounds like
you know the light went off where you
were like i need to become capable of
violence in order to gain the respect i
need and then
you know scale it back from there and
know when to use it and when not the the
light went off
when a year after my father left me my
biological father left me and i haven't
heard from him and i was being spit on
picked on
i was um now indoctrinated into a very
strict military upbringing because my
stepfather was a drill sergeant special
forces it's 4 30 in the morning i would
raise the flag put the hand over my
heart
i would do physical training before i
even start um
school
dress code i was what i'm saying is i
had a hard time with the discipline and
my mother came to me with this box
and she said you know
son this this is from your father
and you know
and i i sat the box across the room
because i i was so disappointed in my
father because he i didn't hear from him
so finally i had the courage to open up
this box i opened up the box and inside
this box was four contents
it was these vhs tapes that were dubbed
right and uh i ran and they were written
in vietnamese i didn't know what you
know how to read vietnamese that i just
randomly picked up tape i threw it in
the vcr
it was the art of budo
if you don't know what that means it's
the martial arts side being samurai
the way
bushido
you know i was uh very defeated at that
moment and then this
this image of samurai this image of a a
higher
mobile way uh
more way of living a moral values
to to dedicate your life to being a
warrior to to help others compassion you
know that's the bushido code right
so
if you ask me patrick that was my escape
education
bushido
a warrior's uh upbringing we are in the
samurai culture they're called bushi the
study of being a warrior samurai
so at 16 you know i i tried out for uh
you know a lot of the intensive training
the physical training i know i needed
for special ops
and at 18 there was no direct hire into
special forces back then so i went to
the uh 82nd paratroopers i went to the
long range reconnaissance
amphibious reconnaissance teams and then
i made to special forces at 21.
two were you uh what was the first fight
you ever got into like where you beat
somebody up how old were you in the
first first fight you got into
oh i was beaten almost every day in um
in
elementary school in junior high i
wouldn't say it was uh more me fighting
it was them beating me when did that
stop when was the first time where they
said you know what i just probably not a
good idea to mess with two anymore man
this guy i remember that i started
studying martial arts when i was eight
more the uh discipline my
stepfather was uh he taught me the green
beret side of
combatives you know special forces
hand-to-hand combat
so there was this bully picked on me uh
and i
smashed his nose in you know
unfortunately he shatters his whole nose
um
eight years old no i was thinking i was
at 12 at that time okay i had enough so
by middle school you were ready to yeah
i was that kid you know when you go back
uh when you're wall locker and you have
post stickers like [ __ ] and go back
home like those were normal for me
right and i got tired of it and i
smashed in this kid's face yeah and um
oh man um
i was in trouble you know not only in
school but at home because my father was
teaching me these moves and here i am uh
employing them in a um
a very lethal way because did this
happen consistently or no were you were
you the guy that got into a lot of
fights or no no okay you know i um i
believe in the martial arts i believe in
if we can not fight don't fight so here
here's the story of not fighting so
my father didn't want me to fight right
he said you're not doing it you're
you're going to you're going to go to
school you're going to be this this
you know gifted kid ap classes you're
going to do this right i told you not to
fight back yeah wow yeah because so many
movies were killing moves
because you knew the moves but he said
didn't want you to
even destroy these kids yeah i mean the
moves that
we were taught is to
uh to blow out some of these eardrums by
cupping your hands to put your fingers
through somebody's eyes to just shash
into smashing their face and nose to
break their neck if we need to
um but these are moves that were taught
to him in the special forces and moves
that was given to me but in a in a very
secret manner yeah this is not breaking
balsa wood to get your yellow belt type
of stuff exactly yeah this is true
actual
it's true the art of budo which is the
combat side of being a lawyer so i knew
all that and i was being picked on as
being you know but this this is where uh
strategy came to play because i was a
student of ninjutsu and just samurai and
and i was studying when i say a student
i would study right the the history and
the arts and
the ninjas are always about what about
outsmarting your opponent right because
they were employees of spies right
reconnaissance so i i realized that and
i knew the bully schedule so i would
write down his timeline his schedule and
i'll look at his pattern of life and
then i knew his pattern of life and his
his schedule so i avoid his pattern of
life in the schedule so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]